[Music]  hey everyone I'm ed boon from  NetherRealm Studios and we're excited to  share the return of a classic character  to Mortal Kombat X rape Raiden spin with  mortal combat from the very beginning  and we've had a lot of fun updating him  for MKX  and today we're going to give you a  taste of all three of his character  variations as the guardian of birth  realm Raiden has a long history of  conflict without world so it's only  natural that he faced off against its  current Emperor totalcopies you have no  chance underdog  under blocks out the Sun to burrow away  for it the Thunder got variation  enhances Raiden's lightning attacks  allowing him to string together longer  combos and do more damage  in his displacer variation Brayton gains  new teleportation moves that make him  difficult to contain and more mobile in  combat and finally storm Lord regen can  create lightning traps with wide areas  of effect that allow him to control the  back  [Music]